the 2017 film version of Stephen King's
it's made its mark as one of the biggest
critical and commercial hits of the year
but it wasn't the first time the horror
masters classic 1986 story made his way
to the screen the books original
adaptation a 1990 TV mini-series lacked
a movie sized budget and modern special
effects but it still managed to give
audiences plenty of scares the TV
version of its had a strong cast going
for it including budding young stars and
formidable character actors portraying
the adults with the exception of
jonathan brandis and john ritter who
have passed away since the movie's
release most of its original cast is
still busy with strong Hollywood careers
here's a look back at the original
ensemble and what they've been up to in
the 27 years since Pennywise last reared
his head Richard Thomas TV fans might
best remember Richard Thomas for his
Emmy winning turn as John Boy in The
Waltons
but for horror fans Richard Thomas will
always be remembered as a grownup
version of Bill Denver taking over the
role of the losers leader from jonathan
brandis after its thomas continued his
prolific acting career with more films
like Wonder Boys and the TV series such
as the Americans Thomas also maintains a
steady career on the stage recently
earning a Tony Award nomination for his
role in the 2017 Broadway revival of the
little foxes brandon Crane in the 1990
miniseries Brandon Crain played the
young version of Ben Hanscom who was
frequently bullied by Henry Bowers and
his gang because of his weight around
the same time crane also had a recurring
role on the classic drama comedy series
The Wonder Years as Kevin's close friend
Doug Porter following his appearance in
its train continued to appear on the
small screen and in short films and
these days he makes his living as a
stage actor singer and frontend website
developer during the summer of 2017
crane reunited with some of the other
dairy actors to film the upcoming
documentary penny wise the story of EDS
Emily Perkins Canadian actress Emily
Perkins portrayed the young version of
Beverly Marsh in the miniseries and it
was one of her first major roles but
something about her stint as a scream
queen in it seemed to stick because she
would later continue to star in scary
projects like the x-files and ginger
snaps
nowadays she's taking a break from the
small screen as she enjoys
newest rollers mama Annette's O'Toole
before she became the adult Beverly
Martian it's a net O'Toole appeared as
Clark Kent's love interest Lana Lang in
Superman 3 and after defeating the dairy
demon O'Toole returned to the Smallville
fold by starring a Superman's mother on
the small screen after that was done
however she came back to the realm of
Stephen King for a brief stint on the
small screen adaptation of 11/22/63 Seth
Green long before he became a household
name Seth Green was a foul-mouthed
wisecracking Richie Tozier
in the it miniseries he later rose to
fame with roles in the Austin Powers
film franchise his long-running role as
ours on Buffy the Vampire Slayer and the
dozens of other films and TV shows he's
been a part of nowadays his steadiest
work seems to happen behind a microphone
he provides voices for Family Guy Robot
Chicken and the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and even made it into the Marvel
Universe as a voice of Howard the Duck
in the guardians of the galaxy movies
Perry Anderson for adult Richie actor
comedian Harry Anderson stepped into the
role Anderson is likely better known for
his long-running role as judge Harry
stone in the NBC sitcom Knights courts
but he's also popped up in popular
series like Cheers and hearts of fire
both much like Richie he's always had a
comedy at heart and these days he can be
seen performing stand-up routines and
magic shows around the country
Adam 4 raised a 12 year old Eddie Kaz
Brock was the most timid member of the
losers Club frequently jumping at his
own shadow or complaining of ailments
like asthma that his mother convinced
him he suffered from playing Eddie in
the 1990 miniseries was Adam for Rahzel
who didn't stick with acting for long
after it premiered on television he made
a handful of appearances in TV movies
like where the Red Fern Grows but
ultimately he found a professional
passion in the restaurant business where
he specializes in bar beverages Dennis
Christopher playing the adult version of
Eddie Kaz Bracken the it miniseries was
Dennis Christopher who first rose to
prominence in Hollywood with his
starring role as Dave in the 1979 film
Breaking Away
Christopher went on to appear in many
more films and television shows over the
years including Roswell and starch
enterprise he also appeared in Quentin
Tarantino's Django Unchained and
recently starred in several episodes of
the epics comedy series graves Marlon
Taylor playing young Mike Hanlon was
actor Marlon Taylor who also appeared in
a handful of other television roles as a
child including Sister Sister after 1994
Taylor took a hiatus from acting but
reappeared in 2009 when he co-starred in
the rap drama know thy enemy information
about what he's been up to since then is
scarce but according to Taylor's Twitter
accounts he recently finished filming a
part for an episode in season four of
sci-fi post-apocalyptic TV series z
nation Tim Reed Tim Reed played out the
rest of my kin Long's tail for viewers
as he discovers that it has returned the
27 years after their last encounter like
his younger counterpart Marlon Taylor
Tim Reed also appeared on the sitcom
Sister Sister and continued to act in a
number of films and television shows
including That 70's Show and Treme most
recently read made a couple of
appearances as Bishop Lionel Jeffries in
The Oprah Winfrey Network drama series
green leaf been hella being an actor
isn't for everyone and it certainly
seems that was the case for Ben Heller
who played the 12-year old version of
Stan Lee URIs in 1990 Stan is the most
logical and skeptical of the losers Club
members and hella handled the role just
fine however his appearance as Stan was
his first and the last acting role fans
will get to finally find out what he's
been up to in his post Jerry days when
he appears on the 2018 documentary about
the miniseries production Richard maser
Stan was the one who initiated the blood
oath between the losers Club members
when they were children but when he
learned to laugh to make good on that
promise his fear of facing the ancient
evil again leads him to take his own
life
Richard maser is probably better known
for his work in shows like rhoda and
films like the thing today he's still a
regular on the small screen having
recently starred in The Good Wife and
oranges a new black Tim Curry renowned
actor Tim Curry did much of the heavy
lifting in the 1998 miniseries with his
role as penny wise the dancing clown
while there has been considerable buzz
surrounding bells cars cars modern take
on the character in the 2017 film
adaptation it still doesn't displace
Curry's cheeky performance as a fan
favorite from the first
rotation following it's curry continued
his extremely prolific acting career
with dozens of roles and films and
television shows and even after
suffering a stroke in 2012 which left
him wheelchair-bound curry refused to
slow down taking a voice role in Star
Wars sir Clone Wars and returning to the
Rocky Horror Picture Show realm as a
criminologist in the Fox TV remake and
he's still ready to bust out Pennywise
whenever the need arises
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]